hey everyone Avengers infinity war is
just one week away and we are finally
getting some extended looks at scenes in
this movie too release scenes this week
and one secret scene described in an
interview who we're gonna break down all
of these and point out what you missed
but welcome to new rockstars news it's
our deep dive into all the biggest
stories this week and guys big
announcement right now this moment
begins new rockstars
in seven days but infinite hi it's
Philip called my pitch for infinity week
infinitely week that's why it's not here
you know what you say oh and sick we are
counting down the seconds to thanassis
arrival with interesting in-depth looks
at this showdown all the insight you
need to prepare for this movie to sound
smarter than your friends and to impress
that cute movie theater usher you know
you wanna yes in the show we're gonna
look at clips showing the black order
and Captain Black Widow Cherie and
banner and vision and another secret
scene that Sebastian Stan teased
featuring Bucky along with Nick Fury
another surprising face get all those
details but first I'm Erik Bosse joining
me at this table are Sam I'm opening my
eyes wider than I've ever opened them
check it out welcome everything's off
the rails already let's get started with
our top story this newly released
infinity war scene showing a fight
between Thanos's Black Order in the
Avengers Anthony Mackie appeared on Good
Morning America this week showing a clip
featuring Captain America Black Widow
and Falcon fighting against two members
of famous is Black Order Corvus glaive
and Proxima midnight and even though the
clip is less than 30 seconds from what
we can see the good guys kick their
asses
Black Widow knocks down Corvus glaive
and then she and capped him up against
Proxima midnight with some help from
Falcon and ends with Proxima urgent
Corvis to get up
you can't and BlackWidow says we don't
want to kill you but we will so a few
details to point out in these short
frames first black widow is holding
próximas spear at the beginning and she
uses it to disarm core vessel but then
the spear why is that a black widow sand
and it returns to Proxima suggesting she
can like summon it maybe like Thor with
his old hammer by the way we learned
this week that actress Carrie is
playing Proxima midnight you may know
her from the leftovers and if you listen
closely the Corvis saying i can't hear
let's listen again yeah yeah I don't
know guys to me that sounds a lot like
Peter Dinklage it still hasn't been
confirmed which character he'll be
playing an infinity war the Russo says
said that we will recognize him when he
appears on screen but it might take us a
couple seconds that might mean there's
like CGI coverage was the voice in
destiny to redemption hopefully also
Beulah close cap is using Corvus glaive
and use it to break Proximus spear now
that clave is super powerful in the
comics it like cuts Hulk's skin and as
long as the glade remains intact Corvis
is invincible at least that's how the
logic works in the comics of course now
it's a little unclear where this is
taking place but if you look closely at
the background here there is a saluto
coffee stand overall this kind of looks
like to me like an underground metro
station like the ones you might see in
european cities and our recent trailer
breakdowns I pointed out a shot at
Proxima fighting Scarlet Witch and
vision above ground and what looks like
a European city based on the
architecture maybe vision and Wanda were
like staying in Rome or something like
that and a black border attacked leading
to this fight with the Black Order which
the Avengers aren't able to fend them
off but I'm curious to know what you
guys think does this make you feel
better about their odds against I got a
pro I got a con yeah just about what
we've seen not necessarily the storyline
but the pro is this gives me really big
civil war flashbacks especially xiii
together beautiful I don't can see that
these three have fought alongside each
other so well and that they really do
work like superbly together and that's
one of the
that I absolutely love about the Marvel
movies you know like times where Thor
uses his hammer on cap shield like those
moments where you're like yes as a fan
this is beautiful so getting that sort
of Civil War flashback specially in the
start of the movie loving that not a fan
of CG oh wait a minute you tell me those
guys are real you mean that hair on that
woman says not real boy oh boy are they
not there instant attachment yeah I
think their faces looked okay
like I'm gonna there's like a close-up
of Corvus you like it but then you
looked at their hair moving around them
as they were like kiss been kickin and
stuff and you're like I do prefer that
when they were balls actors no character
and it's not like you know the swarm
that we saw in Justice League and that's
all you kind of get from it you know the
fact that they have weaknesses and the
fact that he's like I can't get up huh
like that was a human moment it's like
someone actually pees himself when
they're singing like we don't address
something anyone have a backpack or a
pillow jacket around my waist it's cool
I totally agree the Mod awesome fighting
it caps action it really like like we've
got a really good sense of it and Winter
Soldier when he fought that French guy
on the boat in the beginning we were
like actually can do this you just
thinking about Darren's oh and she had
to do that and like I don't know what
you talk back from South by Southwest we
had a friend finally throwing up and
she's not a just getting him luggage and
she did the tire blaze oh man
anyway so it's flavors clearly on that
flight - and it inspired way of this
invincible your Glade still attack no
it's not through teas what does it say
yeah not these days uh yeah I agree I
think it is a human moment I'm hoping
that a CGI is still being rendered I
mean they still render stuff right until
like the last second even though I think
they just did a screening of it it seems
like leaps and bounds I mean we'll see
they have its Kerry Coons great her
voice acting it's awesome if it is Peter
Dinklage great voice actor I mean it
looks like they did spend a lot of care
and effort into Thanos's CGI mapping
over Josh :
so as long as that's okay I'd be willing
to let a couple things slide with some
of the other supporting people were
complaining about the way thinness looks
he looks fine he looks absolutely fine
he Steppenwolf when he was talking was
like a look like you could see the
puppeteering of like it looks like a
PlayStation 1 video game it was rough
and it was like what will make him
aliens yeah but no it with fantasy looks
good and a wide shot of all those
characters looks great yeah yeah mind
you comment below what you think's a
nose actually looks like does he look
like a purple cabbage does he look like
a baseball that's been thrown too many
times listen Bruce Bruce Willis some who
described him just bruises covering
everything if they got Bruce Willis to
play tennis just not up his alley Sally
whatsoever but I would have loved it but
yeah excited for the movie yeah I know
we talked about these things that makes
me excited always watch them but I'm
just like I have this movie my mind yeah
the fight I agree with the fight
choreography here I think that it does
look terrific
and it seems like too easy of a win for
the Avengers here right this has to be
in like the opening act of the movie
there's no way they defeat them that
soon they're gonna emerge
in the beginning of the movie because
that's a very formulaic and it would be
copying Civil War quite a bit of just
the early strike the three of them
together Oh what is this kind of you
check in check in where they are and it
might also just serve to remind us of
where the battle lines were drawn at the
end of Civil War
like we got another video coming out
next week that like it was gonna look
into exactly how Civil War set the stage
for infinity war it's kind of like a
remind you of previously on because the
way things were left in the Civil War
were we're done in a very specific
reason by the Russo brothers to make it
really interesting in the first part of
this movie to see how these characters
would have to come back together and how
they've learned to fight on the same
side again
there's none of these trailers do you
see Iron Man in Captain America in the
same scene it'll be interesting to see
how they don't at all there's not even
overlapping group yeah yeah well let us
know what you think about the scene but
we are going to move on to our trivia
question this week stain and the theme
of infinity week a civil war oh okay
in Captain America Civil War Hydra uses
a random sequence of words as an
activation code to brainwash the Winter
Soldier what is the last one the last
word or words
okay our question and answers are in
later in the show we'll reveal the
answer this trivia question the closest
is decided by our judges will do our
sign off goodbyes me in the video
meanwhile the loser as always what the
cleverly rif are on are in other news
headlines but for now let us move on ooh
boy quick update here guys since this is
new rockstars news we want to cover all
the big stuff you need to know about not
just infinity were stuff
Steven Spielberg has attached himself to
direct a movie adaptation of the DC
Comics blackhawk Blackhawk was a guy who
led a team called the Blackhawks or the
Black Hawk squadron it was a group of
ace pilots during World War two of
varied nationalities it was actually one
of the older DC Comics series originated
in the 40s during the war there is
actually a black hawk Easter Egg and
Wonder Woman last summer you can go
check out our breakdown of that movie
for that
so yeah that'll be interesting to see
Spielberg tackle that I guess he had a
really good experience with Warner
Brothers on ready player one and one but
the whole vibe of that definitely sounds
like it's a Wonder Woman's expansion
yeah yeah it's it's Indiana Jones but in
planes it's like right now cuz now it
just the idea of what the what the
Blackhawks do in the comics it's like
yes Steven Spielberg's done this before
it's nostalgic he loves it also fun fact
when comic started die down before the
50s before they create like Barry Allen
and Hal Jordan the biggest comics they
sold were Superman Batman and Black
Hawks that was like he was extremely
popular because of his adventure so it
makes it's kind of cool to bring that
back very nice all right let's uh move
on to another extended clip released on
Good Morning America
okay everybody with more and more
details coming out about Avengers
infinity war one of the extended scenes
released this week showed us shuri black
panthers sister working with Bruce
Banner to save vision Sheree uses one of
her Coolio beads to scan visions body
and protect a hologram of the mine stone
and yeah banner and Sheree exchanged
some tech gobbledygook about visions
structure being polymorphic and banner
having to attach each neuron non
sequentially and Sheree just how hidden
banner by saying he could have just
reprogrammed the synapses to work
collectively we all got that joke yeah
actually to quickly explain what they're
talking about here banner is referencing
the scene in age of Ultron when he and
Stark brought vision to life they had
just recovered the Android that Ultron
had started to build using the mind
stone stark proposed instead of
destroying this Android to use Jarvis as
the androids inner OS which eventually
led to two vision coming life and now
banner is saying it the way they did
that is by going nerve cell by nerve
cell in the living tissue and attaching
them to Jarvis's programming polymorphic
refers to a language in computer science
which in which one interface in this
case Jarvis connects with different
variables in this case of various nerve
cells and of his vibranium enhanced body
Sheree suggestin a suggestion is to
reprogram the nerve synapses to work
collectively similar actually to how her
vibranium tech works in which T'Challa
can simply think I would like my suit on
please and then the vibranium
organically weaves around his body
and unlike vision he doesn't need the
magic of an infinity stone to do this
okay that's I probably made it more
confusing but essentially per second I
thought you were just gonna give us a
breakdown of age of Ultron I was like a
little bit bummed and then that was
really because I had to kind of like
re-examine be like oh that's exactly how
they that's it that's interesting that
there they bring about that detail here
I just got from that she's sassy and
smart that's a good comeback right
that's essentially what she's saying
here she conceived is something that the
two smartest scientists in the world
Tony Stark and Bruce Banner overlooked
and I like a vision is learning that he
might not be the most perfect version of
himself that he previously thought he
was he's kind of got that look like hey
come on fix that though I mean his
body's built like he could his blink and
then just like real changes no it's
collectively yeah there was an Easter
egg so it's like no vision actually
doesn't wear put clothes on he makes his
body make the clothes and I was like
wove a sweater but guys be on this tech
babble it's interesting to think what is
the context of this scene well in the
background you can see cap into challans
starlet which it seems that they had
brought vision here after the Black
Order tried to steal the mind stone from
visions head and now they're analyzing
visions anatomy perhaps hoping for a way
to safely remove the mind stone without
killing him now a few questions for you
guys one do you think this is even
possible to do that and to who do you
see as a smartest character now in the
Avengers universe I think they're gonna
make a decision where it's like removing
this down we will kill him oh yeah maybe
had to die yeah maybe I mean I don't
know like if she's able to reprogram the
whole body she has access to technology
that is just leaps and bounds ahead what
were used to like we've already seen
like with some mountain Freeman's
character buh buh buh fine what machine
definitely goes to Wakanda with them too
and so you're just like he's just a
little salty probably walking rising
physical can't why it's a machine that
helps him walk it's like he could anyone
want to help me help help a friend out
I'd be really helpful
I usually in the comics it's like this
other comic book II reason he doesn't
have the soul stone up there it's a
different character that has some soul
stones at a more read or the mind stone
I'm get yes I'm warlock has the soul
stone this is the mine stone yeah
getting them confused you
like a solar beam and so he the way he
doesn't he doesn't need to eat he just
absorbs like ciliary doesn't need to
play but hey maybe let's give it on a
maybe yeah I think uh it seems like this
might be part of visions arc in this
movie right like do I need these Sol
snow is or do I need the mine stone is
that the whole source of my my power and
my identity or can I detach it for
myself and I am my own person there's
gonna be a moment with Scarlet Witch as
well she'll be like I do not want to
lose you I also I love the scene in
Civil War when he's like I don't know
what this is like I don't know if it's
me or if I it or I can use it they do
have a really beautiful moment Bertha
though he's actually it was great really
appreciated that they talked about fear
and what it means to be both of them
they're like we don't really know what
we are and so but it's okay because I'm
not really got stop making sweaters
smartest character in the Avengers
universe guys it sure sounds like it
sixteen-year-old Cherie is just like
wiping muffled yeah she's young right
now like just imagine how even more
brilliant she'll get again she's had
access to technology that hasn't really
existed
anywhere else apart from Oakland oh so
that's you know a bit of a head start
but she's schooling these guys it's
beautiful it's beautiful and some people
were like well she'll be the new Iron
Man I was like sometimes she's black
panther or she could just be a scientist
who makes up the whole world she can
just be Sheree and she could just be
herself and have her own character we
all need to reassign someone else's
mantle mmm that's a good gift yeah Robin
is dying guys yeah well I can't live
without personally I think Rocket
Raccoon might be the smartest characters
I was thinking about like who like maybe
on some of the fringes who maybe hasn't
had a chance to show off their
brilliance
thank super smart he's real good at
Legos but he's not gonna be able to
design a computer not he hasn't had a
chance to yet that guy just knew those a
me likes batteries were worth something
I think he's like one of those
intelligent evil types that just uses
his intelligence for bad things like
Zack Morris
from Saved by the Bell he's too smart he
got a perfect score on the SATs and he
used it for evil
watch out Zach Morris's Zack Morris's
back there's like a great web series
about horses trash about how he's like a
rotten rotten person who exploits all
this I'm not Zack Morris time out don't
really know then I live dual identities
and realities anyway guys let us know
what you think about this scene do you
think visions whole identity is based
off of his infinity stone or or gem as
some of you only comic readers or quick
to point out or do you think that guys
are fun other intelligent people who
were missing out on does it can't they
just all be friends and scientists don't
have to bicker about everything or
compare their intelligence let us know
what you think guys remember to
subscribe to new rockstars and follow us
on twitter at new rock stars and weigh
in and keep an eye out for other
infinity award videos that we're gonna
be doing thanks guys
let us move on to another quick update
from this week it sounds like the
upcoming x-men Dark Phoenix movie which
has been delayed already from November
to February 19th will be or could be the
final x-men movie under Fox's Marvel
brand before the property moves back to
Marvel Studios under the merger with
Disney now this comes from a tip from an
insider at Fox it's not confirmed but it
and it's not really clear how this would
affect the New Mutants which has been
delayed twice from this is April this
month then back to next year and now
planned release even later in 2019 in
August 20 19 or how it might affect the
planned x-force movie which Drew Goddard
is scheduled to begin shooting in
October to do sinister six they cancel
all those plans so he's out of work and
now it's x-force I think they're gonna
cancel it again even though we want it
give him a break he's great yeah it's
it's interesting to see because there
was another article that came out a
couple months ago about how there were
six planned x-men movies despite the
merger and they were talking about doing
a gambit movie in a Silver Surfer movie
in a Doctor Doom movie oh yeah all these
things are just in development nothing's
been like started shooting yet but yeah
I hope that this merger doesn't get too
rushed to cancel some of these cool
projects that could have been made Hey
Inhumans is important dang it it's
humans it's Akito they live in Hawaii
now okay let's move on to another secret
scene that was leaked this week okay
everyone recently we got a very
interesting clue about Avengers infinity
war from none other than Sebastian Stan
Bucky the Winter Soldier the movie stars
and directors have been hinting at a
massive battle set-piece sequence
something like the airport battle in
Civil War but even bigger they've
indicated somewhere around 40 major
characters involved in the sequence kind
of like a two-page spread in a comic
book that you just have to keep folding
out and folding out to see everybody in
a recent interview Stan said this about
a quote there was one scene I think we
where we had everybody they were there I
can't really talk about that scene but I
knew it took them three months and
planning this scene to have everyone
there if you look around and you just
saw everyone from samuel l.jackson to
michael douglas
to Michelle Pfeiffer interesting yeah
well see well Nick Fury and the older
ant-man Hank Pym that's Michael Douglas
character I'm not showing up in any
trailers a promo footage and Michelle
Pfeiffer is playing the original wasp
Janet Van Dyne in the upcoming ant-man
in the wassalamu movie she hasn't shown
have been any trailers yet the first day
at man established that Janet Van Dyne
was missing in the quantum realm the
microscopic dimension where you just
shrink endlessly forever and ever and it
looks like the sequel will focus partly
on the search for Janet but no one
expected her to show up in infinity war
Stan may have gotten confused and he
might be referring to the next movie
Avengers 4 which is being shot around
the same time as infinity war was but
Stan's interview was centered on this
movie that's what they're asking about
so I don't know do you guys think we
could see the quantum realm play a role
in infinity war and why how might the
quantum realm connect to what we already
know about this movie story that's a lot
to do that's a long no set pieces I mean
obviously they have to 1up themselves
every movie and they're like alright we
had this amazing you know the whole of
Civil War was just fantastic how do we
raising up the stakes yet again I don't
think it's outside the realm of
possibilities I also think the
Sebastian's dent is a bit of a troll and
I was feeling that he is watching with
us yeah I think either it might have
been confusion and he was just talking
about the two movies he's working on the
same time when this might all be part of
the same event so that's why saying that
we've now reached like this new stage of
stakes in this world and maybe that's
what he's referring to or yeah he might
be trying I'm having trouble deciphering
whether it was a slip of the tongue or
like he knew what he was saying and he
just michelle pfeiffer is such an
interesting name to bring up you can you
can bring up any of the 76 characters
that are gonna be in this big showdown
it sounds like either ant-man the wasp
takes place before infinity war which
would make more sense because if
everyone died at the end of this it's
like whoa what's going on earth is dead
we gotta get this weird suitcase with
some Pym tech make sure we get that back
I was thinking it's the other I think
it's the other Avengers he's shot they
shot it they are done with both movies
he they both if he's in that scene he
would have known about it so he may just
gotten I would be really excited to see
how the quantum realm because I love how
like the the that that other dimension
could work into the story we haven't
really seen the like reality stone in
the reality Jim come into play a lot
there's a lot of talk about how the time
stone or the space stone or the power
stone works but I think the the reality
stone has some other implications that
we haven't really explored and I think
going to the quantum realm could be a
fun way to look into that I think that
the very last second - is about to do
that and they're gonna he's gonna shake
out one of his little Deeley boppers
that shrink things really pop he's gonna
just throw like 50 of them that they
know seems like oh here in time or just
shrink all the Titans like The Avengers
were there it's like hey let's be honest
this is going bad yeah sorry we all had
to make a sacrifice here but you guys
are in the quantum realm now you can't
hurt this realm and I'll come get you
guys eventually I think it wasp - I'll
be down there in a second yeah so
ant-man says that to himself inches out
in space and then we
and then of snaps and cut the black
right what a fun cliffhanger that could
be there's a lot of characters in this
but let us know what you think about
Sebastian Stan's comments do you want to
see the quantum realm and the ant-man
side of the characters or what Nick Fury
might be doing in this movie we haven't
seen him in any trailers either down
below tweet us directly I da vas
remember to subscribe to new rock stars
on what platform are we on you too you
too yeah for all of our coverage we are
in the midst of infinity week everything
we're talking about is infinity war
there's so much to talk about we're
super excited this is happening but yeah
thanks guys but now it is time to move
on to our new rock stars news you don't
want to know the answer to you guys were
nice enough to tweet us questions I'm
gonna fire them at my co-host take out
my microphone they have to answer them
as quickly without hesitation as
possible are you guys ready yeah here we
go mud at mic Oh raw wants to know what
games are you playing and or looking
forward to thank you very much
yeah that's a good answer Sam at nifty
net wants to know most traumatizing
horror movie you saw as a kid I think
the one I can't watch yet is the grudge
it's the one I can uh as I had a friend
who could do the backwards there's just
a very specific thing I remember I went
out to get water to get drink a wired
midnight and I swear I heard that sound
and I'm like I'm gonna die now it's just
a real kid I'm going to die and you can
ask me one of those three there's three
options from to catch me off guard
lightning
what's been your favorite Marvel movie
leading up to infinity war who favorite
Marvel movie lean up to infinity war you
know why I really really liked original
very first Iron Man to me you can't beat
it
it started at all it's so fun I mean
like cárdenas the galaxy i like black
panther
I like the Avengers it's still good
there's great super fun yeah to me Iron
Man is just like the most confident and
what it's trying to be and just seem
like not trying to fit into the
cinematic universe too much yet it's
just being its own thing and it's funny
and it's perfectly clear all these
movies man can we give it up for like
the casting director of the MCU like all
these parts of just you couldn't have
asked for better better casting for that
okay let's take a quick look thank you
all for by the way for tween us those
questions I continue to tweet us sweet
we love hearing from you guys
next up let us take a look at what we
got in the pipeline coming out on the
channel in this next week infinity week
Sam actually has a video that he just
shot yeah for Deadpool to I did the
final trailer breakdown and oh boy I got
some fun theories for Peter Oh Peter
there you are Peter don't remember that
happening in spider-man oh is that don't
get Arthur being infinity week to have a
Deadpool 2 trailer come out because they
did make a fan o stroke in it and that
connects it to the MCU that's enough
also we got another video that we're
working on on a Quicksilver Theory some
of you have pointed out that Quicksilver
might have made a cameo when it's true
is likely sort out it's possible it's
possible if the soulstone can resurrect
before him that's crazy
we're gonna do a video on a ton they're
very excited he would be a scary one to
bring back and make a bad guy alright
right so fans we're also gonna do as I
mentioned a video about Civil War how
it's set up the table for infinity war
big stuff to remind you guys about and
implications on this final conflict and
showdown Sam also has another video that
he who does famous kill thanos has
killed everybody actually
oh yeah in the comics but some are very
specific kills and they are quite
creative and as we're gonna talk about
those and maybe if we were to see those
pop up in this movie
maybe but hopefully not the really
violent ones well what's the most
violent one he definitely punches every
the middle section at a war machine
while he's in the armor just one and
then now doesn't even have the Infinity
Gauntlet on he just does that with his
bare hands
oh what's that Center fake you reckon it
they say and yeah of course infinity war
is coming out on Friday so we're gonna
do a breakdown if there are any
post-credit scenes we will be doing a
breakdown for them and yeah next week on
this panel we will be reviewing oh I
don't know how we're gonna be able to
talk about this in any way that makes
any sense but yeah we will be reviewing
it for you and then the week after that
we'll have it our full easter egg
breakdown of that movie you know how the
end of the drill we are doing ready
player why my phone out of the car well
now comes the time for our 15-second
shoutout where each of us is 15 seconds
to shout out plug ramble out anything we
want Sam take it away
actually if you guys are fans of podcast
I started listening to it today and
iTunes promoted this but it's called the
habitats a podcast about the high seas
experiment if you guys don't know we're
testing out what the conditions it would
be like to live on Mars by putting six
people in a very small habitat on Hawaii
which is kinda like volcanic rock where
they're staying and they have to stay
there for one whole year they can send
you already but it's following them it's
really interesting it's called the
habitat I think they released the whole
season go check it out alright mark I
set out I'm getting back into anime
long time off anime and realized that I
haven't really dough - you haven't
really given my 15 seconds is up no I'm
watching um sort on online actually
basically about this big MMO and when
you're in there the the creator of the
game actually sneaked something so that
you're stucked inside the game yeah it's
really cool and then it gets weird and
everyone's like oh you're gonna like it
then it gets weird and I was like aha
and it got weird you like it I mean it's
fine but no one it should get married
with that at least having a tongue in
the kiss first you know I'm saying
tongue in the kiss well that's too far
so no one should get married that's
bizarre to ask people to engage insane
alright for my 15 seconds two quick
things one to answer your questions we
will not be doing weekly episode
breakdowns of West world but we will be
doing some kind of video coverage on it
stop asking me to break down episode by
episode we just got too much we got to
do but I love the show and we will be
doing some kind of content on it second
thing if you are any country or are
you're lucky enough to get an early
screening of Infinity Ward please do not
tweet me about it don't tweet me
questions about the ending I will not
see it until Thursday night and 8:00
a.m. on Pacific time up until that point
I will not be able to answer in your
questions and don't ruin the movie for
me so I'm so excited get your tweets and
I want to talk to you about it like I
can't do it until I see the movie
alright so please do not tweet us about
this movie know I would lock the door
and turn off the lights people keep
asking about Allegiant can we say no to
that - yeah I mean so gets 400,000
viewers on television that's how many
views we want on our videos for it I
love the show Legion I like to if like
millions and millions and millions
people start watching it yeah maybe
we'll do coverage on it but we can't
like devote our time to cover in every
niche property that we just happen to
like go watch it on TV and then we'll
talk yeah and tweet me about I'll be
happy to talk to you about it on Twitter
viewed is what my thoughts on I don't
know anything that's why a breakdown is
confusing yeah yeah but yeah continues
just pick our brains on it for sure
alright
returned to this week's a trivia
question earlier just to remind everyone
of what it was and then yeah all right
the question was in Captain America
Civil War Hydra uses a random sequence
of words as an activation code to
brainwash the Winter Soldier what is the
last one I don't know last one is I know
what a one is and so do you Erik said
matriarch
Oh Sam said freight car I spelt it wrong
yeah I may have added a GH after C well
mod wrote homecoming I think that was
not it was well the correct answer was
Sam had it right it was freight car free
car was ready to reference it wasn't
coming there like it's a reference to
spider-man which would have made sense
but freight car they think it's a
reference because that's when Bucky died
you fell out of the freight car is a
wink wink nod nod hey it's time to
listen up all ye yeah okay so we're
we're looking up for winner Sam
obviously loser me yeah I think my man
Damon get close yeah mine wasn't even
though was even a word yeah mate Rick
was not sound like it might be okay so
Sam will get to do her goodbyes but you
know we got to her
another news headlines funny I mean what
I will put on my news radio voice and
comedian Rob Delaney who will be in
Deadpool 2 is the dopey every man who
died has been running a fake Twitter
account for PETA
for weeks tweeting about his wife Susan
and beekeeping well Susan must be a very
understanding patient woman to be
married to Rob Delaney noted virgin well
Rob Delaney jockey you tweet about him
being a virgin he gets pissed
oh is it bees was what I was looking for
I come here number two month Riemann
said in an interview that on the set of
black panther he's cast members referred
to him as the Tolkien white guy
I already a good joke so I have to make
a new pun let's see actually I got a
funny story about that someone mentioned
that in the Black Panther junket and the
publicist took it out they actually
physically cut that out of their
interview Oh funny though yeah well as
the token white guy he wasn't
pleasurable enough so they referred to
him as dildo Baggins it was like this
next time that wasn't that good whatever
grab his own face he was like hey
stranger things season three cast Cary
Elwes Cary Elwes from The Princess Bride
my favorite movie of all time he's gonna
be playing a slick 80s politician and
then you've also got Jake do you see
vectoring son of Gary Busey another
popular ad Xander oh come on Harry
always is the biggest I've interviewed
him - any answers your question that was
a great question Maude and Maude and I
was like I fell off my chair yeah he's
gonna be playing a small-town journalist
with a sick sense of humor and
questionable morals hmm
[Music]
dress with sick sense of humor and
questionable morals hope he doesn't ask
any of Hawkins cheerleaders to stand
upside down
another story to move things along
Aquaman has cast Randall Park the actor
from fresh-off-the-boat
playing the character dr. Shin a friend
of Aquaman's father who helped a young
Aquaman develop his powers and later
becomes obsessed with finding Atlantis
hmm how to do this without anger if you
do it wrong it'll be a kick in the shin
if I do this wrong it'll be a kick in
the shin copyright Maude Garrett oh yeah
I apparently looked like this chick
Smallville actors Alison Mac has been
arrested and indicted for conspiracy for
sex trafficking trafficking and forced
labor in an alleged cult oh there's a
sex cult and they like it so next year
yeah they're getting they're getting in
like degrade actresses to like enlist
people and basically they carve an R I
think it is into their skin which is
like the leader whose name something
like rob myself with an arm but it's
like four whack anyway oh well I guess
if there is a list of d-list actors in
it I'm wondering who's next see him next
into the name of the Corps I think I
have one here yeah go for it I bet she's
saying somebody say but she shouldn't
you should go to jail for that how it's
then Allison Mac Wow I felt a shudder
during Smallville with what a time to be
alive
hmm hey how did I do guys let her grade
a a - every single one delivery
past appreciate your feedback hey thank
you say it's I was gonna call it Sam's
suck it corner but that is poor is the
optics on that it's not no man I won the
game but I lost right there day and
night hey if anyone's still watching
thank you so much for joining us for
another episode of new rock stars you
can check out all of our hosts EA voss
air club at mcgarrett go subscribe to
geek balm smart cast check cheekbones
where you're gonna see my Avengers
interviews well you should go listen to
only stupid answers on everywhere you
can let's do a podcast because I'm the
time but other ventures over there
actually I am bringing on someone as a
guest who has not been on the show
before and most of you guys probably
really defensive him so it's gonna be
very fun we at new rock stars like this
video share it makes you hit that little
bell icon see stay up to date with all
the new new rock stars videos time I
nail it see you guys next time
hop clip yeah before 20 everybody bye